[Music]
all right let's go to william in reston
virginia what's up william
hey how are you sir thank you for taking
my call of course man how are you
good
um so what's up so i
i have um
bipolar disorder and panic disorder okay
um and anxiety too um
but i i so i take my medicine regularly
and then i i try really hard not to like
uh
let it affect my life as much as that
possible
um
but over like the last months and a half
maybe two months um i've been having
like nightmares like kind of
consistently a couple times three times
two to three times a week probably where
they
really like uh
affect my sleep and whatnot yeah
so
first of all let me do this
can i stop and celebrate you for a
second
thank you
uh and i and i mean this um
life dealt you a pretty messy set of
cards right
in your seven hand card you got like
you got like an eight high right you got
like a two and a six and a four and then
an eight right
and
the fact that you've said okay here's my
lot
and i'm gonna play
you've got resilience and character that
is absent from our culture largely and i
want you to hear me say directly i'm
proud of you man
oh thank you i really appreciate that um
getting up every day even when you're
feeling really good and still taking
your meds is hard it's hard and if you
haven't been there you don't know it's
hard
and riding that roller coaster through a
panic attack is hard
and that low level burn of anxiety all
day every day is hard and you keep
getting up and you keep doing it do you
exercise too
uh yeah i go to the gym uh
like six times a week dude see i'm
telling you right now man
very few heroes wear capes and you're
one of them
thank you so much hey i'm i'm not
playing i'm not blowing smoke at you i'm
telling the truth on this show i'm proud
of you man what you're doing is hard and
it's it's really good work and it's
gonna pay off generationally for the
people around you so good for you
um
so
you know this but just for the listener
um panic disorder is a common um
comorbidity with bipolar it's just it's
it they go together often um does your
does your panic disorders your anxiety
does it run
um only when you are
are running manic or is it kind of run
uh uh is it kind of a line through the
ups and the downs
um
mainly mainly the well it kind of
depends mainly of the of the ups or like
just kind of general i usually have like
a little bit of anxiety every day and
then like the panic attacks come when i
like
get really obsessed about something that
i may have forgotten or not done or
messed up or gotcha
um so your panic attacks have a trigger
so they're almost more anxiety attacks
than panic attacks huh
yeah the ones that are bad like if i
need to go to the er to get because i
don't like to have strong medicine so uh
you know
for addiction reasons so
if i need to i go to the er and i just
pay the bill i don't mind yeah well man
geez it sounds like you have a system
down which is phenomenal i'm proud of
you dude
um and then ah here come the nightmares
right
the worst yeah and okay so how long has
this been going on a couple of months
yeah well you know i mean i've always
kind of had them but they were really
inconsistent but but the last like two
months ish
it's been more like two to three times a
week i would have
nightmares and what i've tried to do is
limit
i've almost cut tv completely out
because i thought maybe that was it
um
and that did help like lessen the like
severity of them but
um
but yeah like kind of consistent okay
and have so a couple of times a week for
a couple of months
tells me you're getting close to the
point if you're not there already
where you start being nervous about
going to sleep
correct and then that screws up your
sleep which then
really makes the bipolar management and
especially the anxiety management more
of a challenge throughout the day and
now this it feels like that system
starts spinning faster and a little bit
faster does that make you know what i'm
talking about yeah that's exactly what
happens i'm a little nervous to go to
sleep and uh so i have a an app thing
that i listen to before i go to bed try
to help it but um okay i mean the sleep
is still decent though because my
bipolar meds kind of knock me out okay
um
so the like the number of hours like is
is is still pretty consistent but the
type of sleep has been not yeah you're
not getting that good deep sleep and
good rem sleep
yeah okay all right so
there's several things um some
psychiatric medications can cause
nightmares or can toggle the sleep a
little bit and
there's so many different things when it
comes to dreams and nightmares in the
psychological literature but the one
thing that's compelling to me is that
nightmares fall in a particular band of
sleep so if you look at sleep like
like um you know eg bdf like notes on a
on a staff like you're playing guitar it
falls in like a band right and so we get
stuck in this layer here of sleep we
can't we're not up or down it's that
part where you have these thoughts and
your brain's still a little bit on but
your body has been uh
it's honestly it's paralyzed but
basically your muscles
go into uh there's a word for it it's
not coming to my mind but basically your
muscles quit working for a while right
and it's when you when your muscles are
are still working and you're dreaming
it's when you sleepwalk right and that's
right so our body paralyzes itself
basically it's not the right word um but
it shuts down and you get caught in that
in that trap here so some of that could
be medic medication related but i want
you to try something else okay okay
it's called irt
and it's imagery rehearsal therapy okay
and this is for anybody dealing with
dreams there is a correlation there's
some studies that talk about bipolar
disorder and dreams and bipolar disorder
and nightmares
um i do not know of any literature that
says here's how you deal with the
nightmares outside of
different medications and
yeah so
i'm always reluctant to do the black
hole the unconscious sleep um i was
pretty convicted
by matt walker dr walker about the
difference between being unconscious and
being asleep right so i think you're
wise at the same time you gotta take
your magic i take your meds so all right
here's what imagery rehearsal therapy is
all right the goal is
to change the narrative of the story
and this sounds bananas
but the research says it's pretty
effective now i haven't seen it
effective for bipolar disorder so you're
gonna be the n equals one experiment
okay
okay so here's all it means
you take
one or two or three of your recurring
nightmares the ones that are showing up
in some sort of regularity or the type
right so give me an example of a
nightmare that's showing up more than
once
uh like like demons like not attacking
me but like my house okay
um that's
it my family's inside with me as well uh
so that's pretty regular tell me about
it
um
just uh like i'll wake up and they're
they're like attacking the house and
then i have to try to figure out a way
to get my wife and my son to safety okay
um
yeah that's pretty regular um i did have
a couple night terrors here and there
where like you wake up and like you
can't move yeah those aren't very common
okay
and that's that's what we're talking
about your body is stuck in between
those two states right
all right so here's what we're gonna do
we're going to write down
that nightmare
okay
and we're gonna be very very specific
and we're going to change the ending
we're going to focus on the ending of
that nightmare
and we're going to make the ending
wonderful and or conclude with a neutral
ending
where they get inside and then they just
take some diet cokes out of your fridge
and then they leave
or they come inside and repaint the
house for you and turns out they weren't
demons after all they were the neighbors
trying to show you how much they loved
you and appreciate beating it right so
we're going to change the ending of this
in in your awake state
and we're going to write it down and
this is going to dude i know how bonkers
this sounds okay i i know
we're going to write them down and we're
going to rehearse them
probably don't rehearse them on your
front lawn or people will call somebody
on you right
but we're going to write them down and
we're going to rehearse them and
over time i want you to keep a dream
journal so what we would do is we would
say all right i'm laying down to go to
sleep all sudden my eyes are open
it's i look at the clock it's 12 14 a.m
so we're gonna be that specific i hear
the air conditioner humming my wife is
asleep
and i see the shadow
and then i see the other shadow and then
i hear them clanking around on the roof
right you hear what i'm saying we're
gonna be that specific
and then you're gonna open the window
and let them in
and it turns out they're really great
they're just trying to get your
attention because you're a gas meter's
right you see what i'm saying so what
we're doing is we're teaching our minds
and our bodies we're going to reclaim
these stories that they're cycling
through
yeah
that's awesome we're going to rehearse
it and then what i want you to do is i
want you to keep a blank
dream journal by your bed
okay okay
um and the only way you can change
something is by um
uh measure it okay
and so
i don't want you to wake up in four
months and be like oh man these dreams
and you really haven't had one for two
months or you haven't had one for 45
days
and so uh i want you to trap when you
wake up you're like whoa write it down
okay and here's what we're doing okay
the word i want you to have in your head
ownership
i am not going to be subjected to these
nightmares anymore i want to begin to
take ownership of my thoughts i want to
take ownership of my body in the daytime
and let that move through the evening
time
okay yes definitely that's what i want
and here's one other thing
i do love love love this is the nerd
part in me talking about dreams
walk me through that one you just
mentioned real quick
so there's demons coming over the house
what does it look like what does it feel
like and don't put yourself into a panic
attack okay so stop before you get there
um but okay talk to me about it
uh usually uh so we live in a townhouse
uh so it's like a two-story
situation you know and upstairs
downstairs so we we live upstairs and
then downstairs the living room all that
good stuff um but it's all fenced in and
everything with our neighbor um
so usually it's like at night when they
come and usually like for some reason
the trees are on fire we do have quite a
few trees in our
um
little complex thing and they kind of
just like
like literally like uh like almost like
a medieval siege like type of maneuver
where they kind of surround the house
and then like just start taking down the
fences which would be like the door or
the windows to my son's room which are
on the second floor
and then once they get in the house
usually when i panic and i wake up okay
um
can i tell you something
yes
your kids are lucky to have you
and
you probably beat yourself up over the
bipolar and some of the choices you've
made while having a low season or an
upseason over the years is that true
uh yes very true
um
your wife's lucky to have you she's
married to a hero
and at some point sometimes our brains
will recreate stories that either
reinforce how weak we are
or give us an opportunity to
do something
in our dream state that we can't we
don't believe we can do in in real life
so hear me say your kids are lucky to
have you
and your wife's lucky to have you and
you're lucky to have them
do you live in a safe neighborhood
oh very safe yes yeah all right
so
they don't need a new kind of hero they
got one
they got one in you
and if you every day that you take your
meds and every day you get home from the
gym
i want you to think damn right
with that with that
smile on your face they got me
yeah you know what i mean
yeah i do yeah it's
yeah
yeah it's hard to like think about
things that i used to do like but before
and now like i just
um
i i really want to show like myself and
my family that like
this is not okay but it's
we i can manage this and i can do what i
want to do in life just despite
uh
you know a couple you know once or twice
a month i might need to call out because
i got to go home from panics but other
than that
the thing about bipolar is it always
feels like so i'm going to connect your
dreams to the real world that you're
being hounded
they're coming for you and any mess-up
they're coming for you're going to get
inside
and i want you to flip that over
now you're in the driver's seat you know
the path forward you just got to get up
and do it anyway
and so those that's true those shadows
that have been haunting you for so long
the only person who doesn't see the
difference now is you
let the shadows go man they can't get
you anymore
yeah you're right you've created a new
path for yourself forward
so one thing that is important i think
is to always ask yourself it does
there's not a lot of scientific
literature here but it's more counselor
stuff
but i always want to ask myself what's
my dream trying to tell me
okay what's trying to tell me
and your kids don't need a different
kind of savior and the shadows aren't
coming for you anymore because you got a
plan
and you're just going to execute the
plan
right
yeah exactly i'm really really proud of
you and you know this i just got to say
it anyway
protect your sleep with all your might
okay so if this doesn't work in a couple
of weeks
um or your panic attacks increase please
go see your doctor okay and let's let
them know about the uh
um
about the increasing frequency of your
nightmares we can go from there is that
cool
yeah definitely dude hey will you reach
back out and let us know if this works
yes i will
hey if it doesn't work blame kelly this
whole thing was her idea uh
it wasn't at all it'll it'll all be on
me um but let me know and uh i'll be the
first i'll let everybody know if you
call me back dude i've tried this for
two weeks as a suicide ever my kids saw
me rehearsing a dream in my
mirror in the bathroom and that was
weird and then it didn't work um give
that a shot
um
and let me know how it goes man i'm
so proud every time i talk to somebody
who's wrestling with bipolar and they
got a plan and they've got a management
strategy and they got a team around them
it just brings so much of joy to my to
my life because
it's a microcosm of everybody
everybody's got hard stuff bipolar is
really hard
those are hard stuff you gotta get up
and you gotta do it anyway i'm proud of
you brother william i'm so proud of you
man and your kids and your wife
everybody
has their hero man way to go